this
so
[Music]
sure i remember last april
the hearing was held in judges chambers
but the story was all over town
a really vicious crime
judge parker was in no mood for coddling
this was no slum case
it couldn't be blamed on poverty or
physical neglect
just a kid who thought he was tough
so tough that he didn't care what he did
to people
or what people did to him
when judge parker threw the book at him
he didn't back down an inch they said
why should he care that a man had been
crippled for life for a measly dollar
and sixteen cents
it was tough on everybody
that was the title of my editorial tough
fun everybody
i approved the verdict wholeheartedly
i know
i discussed your editorial with some
friends the day it appeared
but we thought it was more than the
dollar and sixteen cents that caused
that boy to strike out with a wrench it
was something much deeper something that
should have been noticed in him long
before the crime was committed we felt
we talked that afternoon about setting
up services in kent which would help
spot this kind of trouble earlier
marian wright said that the mental
health association had been considering
the same idea for years but they haven't
been able to swing it alone
well i thought we could all work at it
together and kitty anderson said she
thought the state government had
budgeted funds to help communities like
ours
that's all i needed
i wrote down the name of the particular
department she'd read about
at least i could try
well the following tuesday we went down
to the state capitol with marion
and we met mr ashley there
he's in the offices of the community
mental health services
and he said he understood what we were
talking about but he said that the state
sometimes does help they have to know a
lot more about us i'll just bet well as
usual i was running away with myself
but mr ashley said the state couldn't
help us unless we could show that the
town itself was involved he didn't mean
just a few active ladies he met the town
local government business people
professionals educators you know and
everyone who has a responsible role in
the company all of them
enough to guarantee that we're
undertaking this thing seriously
undertaking one thing that's just it we
first have to make a survey of our needs
and our resources
that's the first step
that's why we're setting up the tent
committee for children
mr ashley has promised to come at least
once a week for the next few months to
help
who's on the committee
well i have it here
marion cox he's representing the mental
health association
john brinker for the schools jane
anderson for the voluntary agency
dr wheeler the psychiatrist for the
medical association
bill knox for the junior chamber of
commerce you know judge gerhart and i'm
hoping that you'll represent the press
i'm approaching others clergyman
business people
it's going to be a big job
good job
i couldn't even see what the job was
fact is while i run the newspaper in
kent i don't consider myself a town
leader
if i can get out a fairly readable sheet
keep the advertisers reasonably happy i
figure i'm doing a man's job
so i'm not one for committees in general
and this time it was all especially
vague
i couldn't see what sarah was getting
after
kent isn't perfect what town is but it's
not a bad place we live pretty well the
slums that i knew as a kid are just
about gone
we've just about doubled our education
budget in the last 10 years
and we're proud of our health services
and all the other agencies in town to do
community work of one kind or another
besides
how do you survey the mental health of a
town
sure lots of strange characters and kent
so what i do some pretty foolish things
myself sometimes no i i wasn't buying it
then i began to find out through my own
paper what a survey was about
for the next six months people all over
town were asking and answering questions
how were our school administrators
coping with their problem children
do our businessmen have an abnormal
labor turnover
where do we go for help when we have
vexing personal problems
what are the pressures in kent that push
young people toward crime
committees of our own people were asking
the questions but they were being helped
by this fellow ashley who came to town
occasionally to work with the chairman
turns out that i'm not the only layman
who'd need help on a survey it's an
extremely complicated job
and my committee friends were mighty
lucky to have a pro around to help plan
their questions to interpret the answers
to help them get to significant facts
ashley even went out himself on some of
the more important contacts for instance
he was the one who went to see dr nolte
our public health officer to tell him
what the survey was trying to do and to
find out what his special problems were
they talked about the emotional problems
that they'd run into in public health
work and when i have time i try to see
some of these less involved cases myself
there is an interesting case
the mother resisted rehabilitation
surgery on the child for six months
miss evans the nurse in charge was at
her wit's end
finally we got together with her
supervisor
and learned that the woman lives in
mortal fear of what she called the knife
we worked on educating her in the
subject of modern surgery you can see
the results for yourself
i wonder if you realize the number of
cases that we see here that resist
treatment for one hidden reason or
another
personally i don't have time for half of
them no other skill for that matter
well if the community could develop some
kind of psychiatric facility perhaps
then you could get some help on the more
difficult cases
and could we use it
some of the chairman who thought of
public health is dealing with water
supply and epidemics were surprised that
dr noley was so interested in mental
health and illness
don't surprise me too as a matter of
fact
for at the public meeting held to
announce the survey results
dr noley took the lead
in asking for the establishment of a new
mental health agency he praised our
local psychiatrist
and the nearby state hospital
but he said that the facts pointed to
kent's need for a full team operation
that would be the nucleus of a
community-wide assault on mental illness
there are many agencies in town
including his own
who could help in this important
campaign if we had a central
organization staffed by specialists to
guide the doctors the teachers the
judges the policemen
the social agencies
and the many other groups whose work was
involved with the emotional problems of
the people they were serving
then there was a report from mrs block
of the mental health association who
said that her group was in absolute
agreement with dr nolte
she had many startling facts and figures
showing the need for increased mental
health services for people of all
economic levels in kent
one of the surprises of the meeting was
old ken hoffman who got up to say that
he was with this idea 100
as a merchant an employer of many years
of experience
he had learned that people's feelings
determined how they worked and lived mrs
flanagan spoke for the pta
in spite of the improvement of our
school she said the disturbed child was
being neglected
the mentally ill the [ __ ]
the social failures of tomorrow
were in our classrooms today
now is the time to help them
our executive committee has very
carefully gone over the reports you've
heard tonight
with the help of mr ashley our
consultant
and i'd like to make to sum up my
recommendations to you
one
we need facilities to treat children in
adults with serious emotional problems
we must get them
two
we need to try to ensure a good
emotional environment for everyone in
our community
and three
we must help the various professionals
in town do a more effective job
when they deal with the emotional
problems that arise in their everyday
work
and that's how kent decided to set up a
community mental health center
i still didn't know what it was all
about but the people wanted it and
selected a group to get it underway
[Music]
the new board had their first meeting
that very evening after the general
meeting there was plenty of excitement
and good will
a lot of hope some highfalutin plans
but ashley told them it would not all be
easy going
most of their problems were still ahead
of them
and they had better be prepared for a
lot of hard work and disappointment if
they ever wanted to make their center a
reality
i'm not sure they all knew what he was
talking about
the next six months
if there was a dance in kent
it was for the benefit of the center
when young women's league had an art
exhibit it was for the benefit of the
center
there were concerts bizarres
fashion shows
they all made some money i suppose
but the total wasn't even a drop in the
bucket
i heard from sarah's husband
she was on the go 24 hours a day
soliciting funds pleading
begging
and getting other people to do the same
her network of phone calls branched out
through the city and each call set off
dozens of others it was hard foot
worrying time taking drudgery
but sarah is a real hard worker and she
did raise quite a few thousand dollars
and dr nolte was able to get a small
annual grant from our city government
but
as i had suspected the campaign wasn't
really successful people's hearts
weren't touched
like me they didn't know what this was
all about
what bothered sarah most in those days
was the lack of interest on the part of
the county supervisors
they were essential in this enterprise
and they weren't
giving before sarah took it personally
about that time ashley blew into town on
one of his scheduled visits isn't there
someone in this town who could help you
of course there is
bill watson
well tell me uh
who is bill watson
there's no reason why you should know
him he's hardly here anymore he still
has a house in the valley he visited now
then he happens to be here now
we were kids together
later on in years we're on the same
school board we had a terrible fight
i haven't spoken to him since
you really think he could help
he's full of influence and connections
maybe uh he doesn't remember the fight
with the bitterness that you attach to
it maybe
maybe it's just my problem
maybe that's why i never went in for
help this was just the kind of thing
that would interest bill watson why
hadn't she gone to him first
pride rivalry
the trip to the valley was not an easy
one for her but she went
before she got home that day the kent
committee had the use of one of watson's
empty buildings on murray street for
twenty years rent
one dollar per year
much more important
this was the turning point
suddenly the gates opened and money
began to come in
not long after the county supervisors
and the board of education had pledged
support and then the state was willing
to sign an agreement with the local
group
watson's building was converted into a
modern mental health center but it took
much longer to recruit a professional
staff to work in it they were lucky
enough to get hold of a dr london a
psychiatrist who was soon joined by dr
cling a young clinical psychologist and
mrs powers
one of two psychiatric social workers
they had hoped to get
i thought they were nice people but i
didn't expect any miracles from them
the next six months i vaguely heard that
a few people were being sent to the
center by doctors school principals and
so on
then sarah turned up in my office one
day with this fellow ashley whom i'd
never actually met before
i knew that when sarah brings
reinforcements she's out after something
special
i began on the defensive
lead
i've i've printed all your announcements
i've assigned my best reporters to cover
your news events
you've got twice as much space as any
other agency in town this past year now
forever six sarah be reasonable
i know ralph you've been a very good
friend of ours
even though you are especially old for
much people
but what we need now is not exactly news
coverage i don't think the people in the
town know what the standard is about
what we need is an understanding and a
sustained interest along with the
newspapers to keep our center alive and
active
sir i can't turn this newspaper into a
mental health publication
why might my readers want news
they're not instant psychiatry any more
than they're interested in in basic
science or theoretical economics they
want facts
besides i don't
know what this health center does either
can you write these stories she wants
no but uh your staff can why do you say
that
because they do such a good job of
reporting on human problems every day
what do you mean
well take a look at your front page
today
fellow sets fire to a house over in
maple street because a girl turned him
down
that guy's got problems i'd say wouldn't
you
here's a
traffic accident drunken driver kills a
little boy over in route 57
now why was he drunk and why was he
driving when he was drunk a divorce
story
involving two of the nicest people in
your town a suicide
now how long do you think that woman was
suffering with very terrible problems
here's a girl a high school girl charged
with possession of marijuana what's that
all about how beat does she have to get
mr kohler how did your untrained staff
write this report on behavior related to
emotional problems
it's a honey and you printed it on page
one
so but these are people these things
really happen
i never thought about it from your
viewpoint before
maybe you're right
a mental health clinic
that's technical i i wouldn't know where
to begin
well exactly the same way you did this
the story's there it's got drama and
human interest
some failures
success or two that no one might have
expected
but just go on out there
if you don't like the story don't print
it but go on out and see what's going on
we're not looking for any special
favorites
as a newspaperman i couldn't duck a
challenge like that
i sent out my best people and we turned
out three feature stories
the first one was called people in
trouble
we ran it opposite the editorials on a
saturday naturally we disguised the
names
the piece began with an account of peter
b
a charming lovable little kid
who i wouldn't have guessed was sick at
all yet dr london and his team soon
diagnosed peter's trouble
little peter lived in a world of his own
and he needed careful treatment in a
hospital setting
but without the diagnostic techniques
available at the center
chances are peter's trouble would have
remained hidden for years
when treatment would have been much more
difficult
the second incident was about mrs t
whose problem seemed very serious when
she first came to the center
she'd been referred by the child welfare
department after she'd come to them
about having her children adopted
seems that her husband was sick in the
hospital
and she felt the world was coming to an
end that was when the child welfare
people got dr london on the phone
but it turned out that mrs t was one of
those people who get panicky under
pressure sure she had her problems
but they weren't of the deep emotional
kind
she was assigned to mrs powers for
counseling
by the end of that very first visit mrs
t was in good enough shape to use some
sound advice
in facing a life that included three
small children
and a temporarily incapacitated husband
her problems were real and practical
mrs powers was able to give her some
practical help in solving them
mrs t would see mrs powers again the
following week and go back to the child
welfare department in the meantime
the story ended with a rather full
account of byron kaye a boy of 15 who
could only read fifth grade books
it was pitiful to see him try to
decipher words that would have been easy
for a ten-year-old
as he labored with dr kling the
psychologist in remedial reading
sessions
he showed signs of being bright in
everything except combinations of
letters on a printed page
other afternoons he came to the center
to see dr london who talked with him
about many things
they discussed the boy's friends his
feelings about his family
what he thought his reading troubles
came from
but no real answer emerged
he admitted his eyes were all right in
games and in target practice
it was only when it came to reading that
they blurred when that happened he said
sometimes i feel
stupid and mad
i guess i am stupid
byron seemed to need this false idea of
himself
in the meantime byron's mother had been
coming in once a week to discuss the
problem with mrs powers
so you do set quite a bit of store by
the printed word
well naturally i all my life i've loved
books and my husband too
it's a very important part in both your
lives
yes that's why we were so upset that he
didn't read like the other children in
his class
well and then i suppose i did push him a
little hard
we just can't believe that he's that
stupid
yes that's what i mean
i think you were right byron isn't
stupid
he knew how important reading was to you
well
naturally uh our house is full of books
some evenings we we just
sit around and read and byron chose not
to read he really picked the one thing
that could get to you and really stir
you up
you mean he doesn't read on purpose
not exactly
i'm sure that now byron doesn't know why
he doesn't read but perhaps in the past
many times he needed your attention and
you and your husband were too busy
reading to give it to him
perhaps then he came to see books as his
rivals
and couldn't understand what it was
about the printed page you found so much
more fascinating than you found him
he could easily come to hate reading and
to fear it
couldn't he
i just can't believe that we've
failed
i know you named your boy after a man of
letters
mrs powers did not permit mrs kaye's
guilt to upset her too much but it did
provide a strong motive for mrs kaye's
attempts to change some of her attitudes
we had a lot of mail after that article
and about a month later we printed a
second one lessons in living i called it
it dealt with the educational activities
of the center's staff for example dr
kling the psychologist went out
occasionally to one of the electronic
plants at the invitation of both
management and union
he held discussion groups to help the
workers prepare for the years when they
would no longer hold down a job at the
factory bench it was not money he talked
about he underlined the importance of
making an effort to build human
relationships now
that would be meaningful when they got
older he tried to stimulate them to find
ways of using leisure time which did not
depend on muscle and energy dr kling
reminded them that pensions could not
buy serenity and dignity
mrs powers took her educational work
into school itself she met frequently
with groups of teenage girls
well john makes all the decisions for us
it doesn't make any difference to me
whether we go to the show
or to a malt shop is that bad well i
don't know
what do you think jack
i think it's terrible
all you want to do is boss her around
and just push her everywhere why do you
say that if i want to go someplace i
think i have the right to say it
i mean if i don't want to go to a movie
why should i
and say i want to go dancing well i can
always find someone who'll take me well
i think janet here is the bossy one
i think a boy has a right to say where
he wants to go
he doesn't have to go with me you know
well that's true perhaps but what if you
want to go out with this particular boy
maybe that's why sue lets john make the
decisions i think it matters less where
you go
then uh who you're with
when i was to ask this before if that
was bad is it
no i don't think so at all
that's exactly why we're here to learn
why and how and what we feel about
certain things makes us behave in
certain ways
on other days the girls discussed
marriage their relationships with their
parents many other personal subjects
they enjoyed the discussions
some of the classes were held right at
the center where mental health movies
could be shown
the tuesday and thursday parent groups
often saw films dealing with child
development
after the pictures were over dr london
would lead discussions in which the
parents tried to apply the ideas of the
film to their own problems
often there would be help to understand
the reasons for their own feelings and
actions
often they found that their johnny's
unique behavior was not so unique after
all
talking it over with other parents
helped them to understand their children
a little better
the third and last of the series i ran
on the center was called helping those
who help others
it dealt with the consultative work of
the center's staff
for instance mrs powers was called in by
the public welfare department some of
the problems that had come up in the
handling of deprived children she found
could be traced to subtle negative
feelings of certain staff members
toward the mothers of large families
the very people they were supposed to be
helping
the staff would be given an opportunity
to recognize and discuss their feelings
which should enable them to work better
in these situations
sometimes the community's requirements
took the center staff a long way from
their clinical background dr kling for
instance was called in at one point by
the town's leading architects who were
busy preparing a new housing project
their problem had to do with what were
the special requirements for aged
tenants
should they be in separate sections did
they need ramps instead of stairs were
special cooking facilities necessary
dr kling was pleased at the opportunity
to contribute information that he had
long been interested in collecting
he was able to show the architects what
was being done in certain european
countries to make life a little better
for the older people
who had outlived most of their
contemporaries
the most dramatic incident in the story
had to do with a family whom we call the
joneses
who never knew the community was
concerned about them
mrs jones had died three months before
but now mr jones had an even greater
trouble on his mind
his nineteen-year-old son william had
been acting very strangely in recent
weeks
there were long evenings when william
just disappeared from the house prowling
around the city
mr jones had spoken to dr kenyon his
minister but nothing had changed
although mr jones never knew it
dr kenyon was at that very moment
discussing the case with dr london
who had come to the rectory to go over
some center committee work
when they had finished their business
dr kenyon had brought up the matter of
william jones
in telling dr london the story he
emphasized the fact that bill had been
surprisingly composed
at his mother's funeral
no tears
no outward signs of grief
that can mean trouble sometimes
and i missed it completely
then when he started fighting with his
father and his sister blaming them for
his mother's death
i tried to talk to him
soon i realized i was up against a blank
wall now he's left his job and i know
he's in real trouble
and i can't help him
as you know there's a big difference
between normal grief
and pathological depression i certainly
wouldn't mention a diagnosis on what
you've told me
i think this board needs a more thorough
study before a decision can be made
i think i'll call dr right it's a wise
thing to do
bill jones was living his bad dreams
[Music]
he felt that his mother had been
murdered
in him there was a deep urge to strike
back at anything at anybody
[Music]
the decision that dr kenyon had taken
that night averted trouble
perhaps serious trouble
for in less than a week
bill would be in a hospital under
treatment for severe illness
that story packed a punch
because it made the work of the center
mean something that our readers could
understand
those articles were printed three years
ago now the center has a planning
committee deciding what still has to be
done in our town in the field of mental
health we're trying to encourage our own
hospital to handle certain mental cases
that don't really need to be sent off to
the state hospital
we want to do something about alcoholism
in our town and there are many other
problems
we are looking for new ways to reach our
adolescents and with all the help they
need to grow into mature adults or to
cope with the changing values of the
modern world uh how come i'm on the
board you ask
well it's quite a story
you know that byron k that was that
first article we wrote
that's my oldest son
[Music]
he starts college next year
so i feel i have a stake in this
community mental health business
don't you
so
you